[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire après jean luc mélenchon le
général de villiers jean pierre
chevènement marion maréchal françois
rufas et david lisnard le maire de
cannes que je reçois pour un entretien
purement politique vous avez été réélu à
cannes l'année dernière avec un score
historique +2 88% des voix dès le
premier tour un record en juin dernier
vous avez lancé votre propre mouvement
que vous avez baptisé une nouvelle
énergie et françois baroin vous êtes
désigné comme son successeur idéal à la
tête de l'association des maires de
france le vote aura lieu mi novembre au
moment du congrès de la m f si je vous
invite aujourd'hui c'est parce que vous
incarnez une certaine modernité à droite
vous lui servez même de boîte à idées et
puis récolté 88 % des suffrages au
premier tour ça laisse pantois c'est
quoi votre secret enfin du moins est-ce
que vous avez compris pourquoi vous avez
fait un score pareil
c'est un score qui qui n'arrivera qu'une
fois on est ainsi changé je suis bien
conscient et c'est dans un contexte
particulier aussi comme je l'avais
répondu un nouveau confrère j'ai été élu
et qu'un score de corée du nord dans une
ambiance de corée du sud combinaison les
bureaux de vote c'est plus sérieusement
pied ce score a été quand même confirmé
ensuite au départemental dans une ville
qui ne disait jamais ces mères au
premier tour une ville qui est une ville
kahn qui est très contrasté très connue
c'est la ville française la plus connue
au monde après paris mais une ville qui
est une vraie mosaïque un arlequin de
ville historique d'immigration port mais
aussi de villégiature fortunés et mais
aussi de diaspora politique et qui est
une ville provençale ancien française
donc c est avec des phénomènes de
violence urbaine comme partout avec un
taux de pauvreté je le répète souvent
pour un peu casser les clichés qui est
de plus de 20 % la moyenne française est
de 13,8 dans ces villes très contrastées
et si pour l'instant en tout cas
j'ai l'impression d'être en phase avec
ma ville et c'est physique vous savez la
politique surtout au plan local et puis
ça se retrouve dans les élections dans
les yeux je pense que d'abord ce que la
politique que je mène mon équipe plutôt
bien il ya qu on est on est bon sur nos
fondamentaux et on investit en
modernisant améliore en embellie on
transmet donc là l'espace public est
tenu tout en baissant la dette et en
pratiquant la sobriété fiscale riant
réorganiser les services donc un gros
travail qui n'est pas une fin en soi
d'organisation d'optimisation mais dont
la finalité est le bon service public la
deuxième raison peut-être mais je juge
femmes c'est très compliqué parce que
c'est faussement modeste que de
commentaires voyez c'est très compliqué
c'est je pense mme appliquer les règles
que que je donne aux autres c'est à dire
que je sais c'est d'être amère proche
d'être à l'écouté une tête dans la
proximité de prendre des décisions mais
de ne pas tomber dans la familiarité et
de ne pas tomber dans le clientélisme
était alors au début ça déconcerte les
premiers mois de mon mandat il
déconcerté un peu mais mais mais de
l'est d'être respectés cherche pas être
aimé il cherche à être respecté et quand
je dis moi c'est l'équipe que qui
m'entourent dans une ville je répète
qu'il me grandit quand même qu'il y à
2700 collaborateurs etc j'ai réduit la
masse salariale en il ya moins de
collaborateurs mais ça se passe bien
avec les collaborateurs ça se passe bien
que les syndicats même s'ils sont pas
d'accord avec moi il n'y a pas de coups
à bord n'y a pas de cynisme et si je
décide d'une disposition réglementaire
je l'appliquerais à moi ou à ma famille
à mes amis et je pense que ça c'est très
simple en fait mais ça crée une
confiance et que la confiance à
l'alimentent balle alimente le civisme
et peut-être des bons elle contribuer
aux bons résultats électoraux pourvu que
ça dure image de quelqu'un de moderne
dans une famille politique qui est pas
toujours considérés comme très moderne
c'est quoi être moderne en politique
aujourd'hui à votre avis est-ce que la
france encore vides être moderne alors
d'abord moi je revendique pas du tout ça
non mais c'est vrai que je revendique
pas donc être un gars ou là je n'envie
voyez ce que je sais c'est quelque chose
vous me le dites on me le dit pas
souvent d'ailleurs un peu pas toujours
moderne ça vous savez la querelle des
anciens et des modernes c'est dans tous
les domaines je me rends pas compte
alors si c'est le cas et
j'essaie de pas être à la mode en tout
cas mais c'est autre chose à la mode
c'est ce qui se démode 10 écoute ou non
moi je vais bien sûr d'être pragmatique
voyez que vous m'interrogez sur la
pourquoi ça se passe bien pour l'instant
dans ma ville je trouve très prudent
parce que je mens pas sur qui je suis
non plus tiens j'ai des idées j'ai des
convictions je les affirme mais en
revanche quand je gère la ville je met
en adéquation avec mes idées mais je
respecte un projet de mandat et je
cherche pas à adapter la réalité à mes
idées c'est un travers ce qu'il soit que
ceux qui n'ont pas d'idées beaucoup
soient ceux qui ont des idées mais qui
deviennent idéologues et donc moi je
suis incapable de vous dire ce qu'il ya
de moderne ou pas je vous comprenez ça
peut être se dit que par un tiers ou un
observateur je moi je suis qui je suis
quoi je sais pas si mes enfants me
trouve moderne par exemple c'est ma
passion ma mère ou mon père vos modèles
j'en sais rien vous mais alors la
deuxième question est ce que la france
encore en vie d'être moderne
pas sûr voilà hélas alors la modernité
c'est pas une fin en soi parce que
comment qualifier la modernité mais moi
je crois beaucoup à la transmission et
j'essaie je pense qu'il faut conserver
ce qui est bien et puis j'ai enregistré
moins bien un bon c'est d'abord donner
moi si ça répond pas aux ambitions avec
la négation c'est un peu la lumière
moderne mais qui apparaît non plus avec
vous
mais si vous voulez le passé est un
d'abord éclaire le présent et l'avenir
tocqueville et d'autre on dit bien mieux
que moi aujourd'hui et est ensuite même
si on raisonne en marche et parle en
compétition qu'est un travers parfois
le les villes sont en complète des
espaces sont en compétition les espaces
publiquement les longtemps je le dis
c'est qu'il faut les éditorialisé il
faut qu'ils raconter un récit dans une
rue par un mobilier urbain il faut pas
uniformiser les choses et le fait d'être
fidèle à une histoire à une tradition et
c'est un élément d'abord qui donne du
sens de la profondeur de la verticalité
on en a besoin beaucoup on en manque et
mekki mais qui est aussi un élément de
distinction et la distinction c'est un
élément de compétitivité donc je veux
pose jamais moi je suis un libéral je
vous pose pas le
marché et la fidélité à une tradition
etc c'est plus complexe que que
d'opposer des deux jeux mais mais mais
mais est ce que la france a envie d'être
moderne d'abord la france elle n'a pas
d'avis la france il faut pas faire
d'entrepreneurs fils mme quoi s'est il
ya une somme d'individus moi j'espère
qu'ils constituent un peuple là je suis
très très pour ça je suis très fort très
très soucieux de
l'héritage justement d'un renault ou
d'autre et qu'on soit pas qu'un agrégat
de population qui défend les intérêts
particuliers conçoit un peuple capable
de civisme de recherche du bien commun
et mais il est vrai que la question se
pose on voit bien que dans le débat
politique il est très facile de se faire
applaudir en dit souvent sur les peurs
c'est vrai qu'on peut se faire applaudir
sur les peurs mais on peut aussi se
faire applaudir sur la nostalgie c'est
très doux la nostalgie moi je ne suis
pas contre la nostalgie je trouve que ça
apporte de la poésie j'aime bien la note
mais mais en revanche ça ne fait pas un
projet politique
que de temps en temps on dise attention
tout n'était pas si mauvais avant il
faut bien avoir à l'esprit que tout
n'est pas si mal maintenant et que
finalement on quoi qu'on en dise peut
être qu'ils vont lui être jeune en 2021
que jeunes en 1914 par exemple voisard
huot même même plus récemment vous plus
récemment
qu'il vaut mieux affronter une pandémie
avec des scientifiques aujourd'hui que
qu'il ya 200 ans ou au xvème siècle
quand encore la moitié d'un continent
pouvait être ravagé en cinq ans par
l'ape est donc la nostalgie est une est
une douce accoutumance il faut faire il
faut faire attention c'est joli c'est
beau c'est poétique cc il faut mais
c'est comme tout il faut pratiquer mais
pas trop et à votre question c'est vrai
qu'un président macule qui m'a alors ça
fait ça n'est pas très moderne de dire
ça mais moi qui m'ont que je relise j'ai
relu le noeud gordien jambes c'est
pompidou et j'ai aimé cette même quand
je suis à paris j'aime les quartiers
pompidolien mais pas très loin d'ici
d'ailleurs mais j'aime vous voyez cette
capacité à parler à l'imparfait du
subjonctif
à dans la magnifique anthologie de la
poésie être avoir les pieds sur terre
dans le cantal mais aussi faire
l'industrialisation l'électrification a
lancé le programme nucléaire
civile qui est un des grands éléments
aujourd'hui la compétitivité française
qui malheureusement est bafouée et c'est
ça la vie c'est des sociologues comme
anthony giddens cetera qu'il entrait
bien théorisé dans les années 80 de
mémoire mais sait il faut être dans la
continuité et dans l'innovation il faut
les deux c'est et il y en a besoin donc
ceux qui pensent que ont fait table rase
du passé ça finit toujours mal son tour
des dictateurs sans toujours c'est pas
vrai en fait il faut surtout pas faire
table rase du passé en roulant il faut
savoir un petit peu de temps en temps
renverser la table ce qui est pas la
même chose j'ai l'impression que vous
êtes au centre de votre famille police a
marre qu'on dise que je suis au centre
mais aussi
politique de la droite qui aujourd'hui
me paraît tiraillé dans toutes les
directions et dans des directions très
opposés par exemple entre le entre le
entre le le libéralisme et la baie et le
protectionnisme par exemple la droite
elle est tiraillée aujourd'hui le pays
est tiraillé la gauche aussi d'ailleurs
alors oui d'une autre manière d'une
autre manière et après la gauche la
violence de l'affrontement était plutôt
entre gauche laïque un peu puis une
gauche où et quand cette culture etc
pour revenir à votre question c'est une
façon de réfléchir avait compris
d'abord dans votre question là deux mots
en isme protectionnisme et libéralisme
méfiance si le sel c'est à côté moi
j'étais influencé par un libéral qui
était jean françois revel libéral de
gauche en l'occurrence mais qui dit
toujours l'idéologie c'est ce qui
réfléchit à votre place et l'idéologie
c'est quand il ya isme c'est à dire
quand le l'idée devient un système de
pensée un peu holistique et qui est qui
et qui
kiffent crédit qui crée du fanatisme
donc et c'est là que le fallait dix
esquissé ce qui s impose à la réalité
c'est une croyance qui s'impose à la
réalité moi je crois toujours que la
réalité doit s'imposer à la croyance
mais qu'on a besoin de systèmes
idéologiques on a besoin d'avoir une
colonne vertébrale de pensée pour
proposer des alternatives raisonnables
et structurer une action cohérente et
ramener des gens à vous pour vous
soutenir et vous aider et donc entre le
pragmatisme pur et dur qui naquit n'a
aucune existence et l'idéologie
dur il ya non pas un entre deux mais une
sagesse d'action
la droite française aujourd'hui je pense
pour moi qu'elle est à l'épicentre 16
comme moi qui se sentaient l'épicentre
d'une réalité sociologique du pays et
c'est ce que j'ai essayé d'écrire de
d'un peu à mon niveau comme d'autres il
ya beaucoup de deux personnalités
engagées qui produisent des choses
formidables je pensais avant lui
thieriot qu'un député qui produit un bel
ami on est d'accord ou pas avec un
retail au fait qu'ils sont des gens qui
produisent du contenu après on est
d'accord ou pas moi je suis souvent
d'accord en l'occurrence mai mais voilà
aubert réfléchi sur le sur le sur le
protectionnisme et tant d'autres donc il
ya quand même il ya un vrai travail qui
est qui et produits et cette réalité
sociologique du pays mais cette majorité
sociologique ne rencontre pas de
majorité politique et il me semble que
si nous savons la droite et le centre
apporter une offre qui correspond à ce
que l'on est à ce que l'on pratique à ce
que l'on vit autour de trois axes on est
en
en rapproche la liberté contre dans le
libéralisme qui est la principale source
de création c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
toujours aimé cette pensée libérale et
qu'elle protège l'individu mais aussi la
protection que kiki qu'alors
protectionnisme et je m'en méfie parce
qu'il renvoie des lignes maginot et ça
n'a jamais fonctionné vanille en
économie à l'armée en tout cas ça
fonctionne ponctuellement mais à terme
ça ne fonctionne pas parce que ça
entretient des défauts ou des carences
en revanche il faut des protections
s'appelle la réciprocité et on doit être
en mesure de dire nous respectons des
règles nous appliquons des règles dans
nos échanges et dans le commerce en
france des règles d'hygiène des règles
d'accessibilité des règles
environnementales
nous
n'accepterons plus des produits qui font
du dumping sur ces critères là ça
s'appelle la réciprocité est ce que
c'est une protection l'exposé du
protectionnisme c'est des débats un peu
intellectuel mais on est à la
convergence de trois choses 1 le besoin
de liberté on doit retrouver le goût de
la liberté parce que c'est la force
créatrice libertés individuelles aux 5,2
ordre public ce besoin essentiel
qui est qui n'est pas contradictoire
telle liberté moi je les oppose pas je
dis jamais elle
liberté la sécurité est la première des
libertés parce que cette phrase là qu'on
entend tout le temps on peut justifier
tous les despotismes et toutes les
mesures liberticides en revanche l'ordre
public dans un état de droit est une
condition de la liberté est donc un
libertés individuelles deux offres
publiques trois unités de la nation sire
que on a besoin d'une spiritualité
commune des spiritualités commune qui
passe pas l'instruction la culture et de
trouver cet équilibre entre
singularité individuelle
mais aussi et qui passe par une identité
qui est multiple et est donc tout ça
n'est pas antinomique c'est pas
antinomiques mais c'est difficile c'est
pour ça que là où je disais que vous
avez jamais le centre c'est une façon
j'ai l'impression vous essayer justement
de trouver le bon coup là il faut placer
le curseur entre des autres des choses
qui ne sont pas antinomiques ils sont
pas forcément qui ne cohabitent pas
forcément nous avons placé le curseur
d'affirmer des mesures très simples
comment concrètement on retrouve des
liberté créatrice comment retrouve de la
république est-ce qu'il ya contradiction
pas si la contradiction comment larbitre
comment on retrouve de l'unité nationale
et qu'ils soient pas une machine à
broyer justement cette unité nationale
là aussi me semble-t-il la droite est
tiraillé entre la liberté la liberté
individuelle qu'elle a toujours
caressé on veut dire et puis l'identité
j'irais même jusqu'à dire légalité parce
qu'à partir d'un certain nombre et en t
aujourd'hui la droite mais pas seulement
la droite vous avez raison elle est
hantée par l'identité nationale par le
séparatisme par le communautarisme parle
partout ça et qui au fond ça commence à
ressembler à un moment les valeurs de la
république qui connaît tous censés
partager alors que non ce qu'on est
obligé de respecter c'est la loi mais
pas forcément les valeurs et donc on a
l'impression qu'on voudrait plus voir
qu'une tête et c'est une question
fondamentale vous toucher juste
d'expériences de vie moi ce que je
constate dans ma vie de père de famille
un homme avide enfin mauvais jeu de mots
de ma ville et puis pas ensuite j'essaie
toujours mettre en
confrontation en tout cas de l'empirisme
ce que je constate de l'indic tiff et
puis du 18 yves des choses que je peux
lire par ailleurs d'être toujours
autodidacte qu'on est chez de l'autre de
progresser c'est que
précisément à force de ne plus chercher
jésuite de faire ça dans l'ordre on a eu
depuis 14-18 même avant savez comment
c'est ce que les anarchistes en russie
etc mais ça a été canalisée et puis lui
l'absurdité de 14-18 de la boucherie il
ya eu la priorité absolue de la shoah
vous avez aimé 68 donc une sorte de
relativisme qui né de ces absurdités qui
montre que le progrès technique n'est
pas forcément un progrès moral et que
comme disait rabelais enfin c'est
l'humanisme science sans conscience
n'est que ruine de l'âme voilà c'est
fait bon on n'a jamais fait mieux comme
phrase est donc là dessus et lui une
espèce de relativisme or apprendre à
relativiser c'est une forme
d'intelligence mais le relativisme
encore un moralisme consiste à dire que
j'utilise souvent cette formule que tout
se vaut mais si tout se vaut rien ne
vaut à la fin et le relativisme il
produit à dit l'isthme et ce nihilisme
en fait vous le retrouvez dans le
communautarisme c'est à dire que quand
vous dites quand on dit attend
aujourd'hui problème c'est pas tellement
que la république elle peut écraser les
individualités ça a été le cas
lorsqu'elle s'est faite contre les
régions entre dans l'histoire de france
est très intéressant de voir cela la
monarchie d'avoir et ensuite la pluie
qui a continué l'avant de la monarchie
bien continuer quoi qu'en pensent les
révolutionnaires entre la monarchie les
inspirateurs et donc là dessus les
individus là s'ils n'ont pas un au
dénominateur commun qui s'appelle la
nation qui produit des règles communes
mais les règles c'est pas que c'est
comme dit permanence et les valeurs la
république les règles républicaines
c'est un tuyau on a besoin d'un contenu
qui nous rassemble qui nous réunit ce
contenu qui doit transcender nos
origines notre condition sociale notre
éventuel religion etc notre sexe c'est
un substrat qui effet de mode de vie qui
est fait de partager des grandeurs
l'esprit c'est pour ça qu'avec
christophe tardieu on a écrit ce livre
s'appelle la culture nous sort qui est
fait de
de la raison critique de mode de pensée
comme un c'est pas forcément une machine
à broyer là aussi il faut trouver le bon
équilibre mais regardez raisonner par
l'absurde et je refile ma boucle quand
vous me dites ça s'opposent à des
groupes etc mais ces groupes-là eux ni
l'individu moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
la nation et la république est venu
protectrice de l'individu que
l'universalisme républicain et
protecteur d'individus quand vous êtes
dans dans un univers qui ne voit qu'un
élément de votre identité si vous n'êtes
que blanc de plus de 50 ans où vous
n'êtes que maghrébins où vous n'êtes que
riche où vous n'êtes que femme ça
devient un essentialisme et que cet
essentialisme là la meilleure façon de
le contrer c'est l'esprit républicain
c'est là les valeurs qui sont anciennes
de la france sont pas que républicaine
c'est c'est un substrat qui vient de là
delà de la logique grec du droit romain
delà de la grande culture judéo
chrétienne de l'esprit des lumières le
il ya une une permanence de la france et
il ya cet universalisme républicain qui
est pas née pour rien en france et aux
états unis d'ailleurs mais mais mais
notamment france qui est qui et qui s'il
est bien équilibrée permet d'avoir une
unité mais de respecter
l'unicité de chaque individu et ne pas
enfermer des individus dans des groupes
sociaux qui sont soit des groupes
géographiques c'est le problème
aujourd'hui de l'immigration concentrés
dans des quartiers et qui fait que les
individus ont du mal à devenir français
ils se sentent pas français de même j'ai
l'impression que la droite est tiraillé
entre le doigt telle qu'elle doit
défendre ceux qui ont réussi c'est une
preuve d'intelligence d'être tiraillé la
fête gens qui n'ont pas tiraillés du
tout est-ce qu'elle doit défendre ceux
qui réussissent des femmes de 1% ou est
ce qu'elle doit défendre au contraire
les classes populaires et les classes
moyennes alward elle doit défendre la
réussite même chose et cette réussite
elle doit être accessible
évidemment aux classes populaires et aux
classes moyennes je pense que le la
matrice de la liberté c'est là et
d'ailleurs vous avez introduit notre
dialectique entre liberté égalité mais
c'est la meilleure façon de 2 dès que de
créer de la justice sociale or pour moi
l'égalité est indissociable de la
liberté mais l'égalitarisme et un des
maux les plus à emmaüs x à mal profond
du pays on pourrait vous parler du
déclassement le plus grave qui le
déclassement éducatif qui pour moi est
le fruit notamment de l'égalitarisme
pourquoi parce que être libre si vous
n'êtes pas égaux en droits vous n'êtes
pas vraiment libre cirque c'est la ferme
des animaux d'orwell cirque les hommes
sont égaux les animaux de la ferme sont
égaux entre eux mais certaines sont plus
que d'autres ce qu avait repris coluche
et donc c'est donc l'égalité des droits
égalité juridique et moi j'ai un peu
plus à l'égalité de chance
est une condition de la liberté
autrement dit vous être amené à une
égalité de groupe qui fait que à notre
groupe vous domine defacto advitam
eternam donc le donc l'égalité elle et
elle elle peut être composante de la
liberté en revanche l'égalitarisme on
arrive à qui a été cultivée par le de
l'héritage de bourdieu parce qu'on sait
mais on arrive à apparaître à la carte
scolaire qui fait que les les personnes
de ces deux classes supérieures de csp +
et les enseignants tous ceux qui
connaissent les codes ils savent très
bien mettre leurs enfants ne respectent
pas la carte scolaire c'est très bien où
mettre son enfant soit tous deux privés
sous un machin etc mais les personnes de
classes modestes populaires
elles elles sont assignés à résidence
donc au nom de l'égalité et et qu'on
renforce l'injustice et est donc c'est
pour ça que l'égalité est une est une
notion très dangereuse parce qu'elle
peut tourner elle peut très vite
totalitaire très vite et d'ailleurs en
france on est tellement pétri
d'égalitarisme que ce que je vous dis
par exemple moi je pense que si on
supprime la carte scolaire si on informe
bien les familles et qu'on donne pas ce
chèque éducation que nos frydman avait
théorisé qui a été appliquée en suède
dans notre pays par l'émulation par la
capacité des profs d'être libre de
choisir où ils vont enseigner des
directeurs d'établissements de choisir
qu'il recrutait des parents de choisir
une lettre enfants à terme en aura moins
d'injustice - d'inéquité alors que donc
exactement ce que les gens imaginent et
c'est là tout ce que je dis contre
intuitif
vérifiez-le en plein d'exemples donc ce
que je crois c'est que il me semble
après droite gauche tout ça c'est bien
de raisonner comme ça parce que ça
permet au moins d'avoir des dialectiques
et puis d'avoir de la démocratie
finalement quand on a vu que quand on
pensait qu'en disait je prends le
meilleur de la gauche et de la droite
tous les autres deviennent des
démagogues et plus de démocratie on voit
bien l'affaiblissement civique dans
lequel on est en france mais
je pense que moi si je me suis molle qui
vient d'un milieu je veux pas voir mon
domaine mais la pauvre mais enfin voilà
de parents artistes sportifs reconvertis
dans le petit commerce d'indépendants
avec des périodes de croissance de faire
de piles et de prospérité bénévoles
beaucoup plus dur on nous apprend à être
indépendant mais je si je me sens de
droite parce que je crois à la france
créatrice je veux être moi-même
indépendant c'est ce que j'essaie
d'inculquer à mes enfants et surtout que
là je pense que la droite doit défendre
l'égalité des chances chacun doit avoir
ses chances or aujourd'hui ce système
égalitariste il le il nous assigne à
résidence identitaire ou à déterminisme
social on pourrait le développer
longuement et c'est en quoi je suis je
pense que le
libéralisme intelligent peut être la
meilleure source de progrès y compris le
progrès pas de progressisme de progrès à
la mouche ou autres tiraillements entre
l'europe et l'indépendance nationale
là aussi on a l'impression que c'est il
ya des va et vient permanent bien sûr et
qu'il va falloir un moment donné faire
un intérêt de voir là dessus à faire un
choix
l'europe est un est une source
d'indépendance nationale et de puissance
il faut raisonner en puissance on a
besoin de résonant puissance la
politique c'est ça si on raisonne pas en
puissance on devient un moment donné un
puissant donc
et donc l'europe est un levier dans un
monde multipolaire et on a besoin dans
certains domaines d'avoir une taille
critique sur la recherche et
développement sur certaines filières
industrielles sur le numérique qui pose
des questions de liberté on a besoin
d'associations européennes de
coopération européenne et donc moi je
pense qu'on a besoin d'une institution
européenne l'union européenne qui
ritualiste cela qui donne des
rendez-vous qui stimule les coopérations
en revanche on est devenu dans un
système qui est supra nationale alors
moi je suis pour l'international pour la
coopération européenne pas pour la supra
nationalité et
et là dessus c'est en cela que l'union
européenne devrait être réformé à mon
sens pour que l est elle ne pourra
l'être que si on parle de projets dès
que vous avez des projets vous arrivez à
faire des alliances et il est vrai que
souvent c'est un peu une tarte à la
crème dire on doit faire un airbus de
six airbus de là mais on a raison parce
que l'airbus a fonctionné voilà c'est
une magnifique aventure européenne
autour d'une finalité même et qui est
donc entre la simple coopération
internationale
assez aléatoire et est un machin dure
aux critiques il ya la possibilité
d'avoir une union européenne qui
autour de projets validés compris par
référendum européen pourquoi pas mettre
des moyens en commun avec des objectifs
communs d'évaluation commune c'est je
pense que c'est une forme plus moderne
de construire l'europe on est un peu au
bout de ce système qui a été plébiscité
jusqu'aux années 90 et qui depuis les
temps mais vous voulez dire qu'il
faudrait la réforme et ça veut dire la
démanteler en partie parce qu'elle est
partie bien ou bien plus loin l'europe
aujourd'hui disons l'a recadré par la
démanteler la recadrer
recadrer le pouvoir de la commission
européenne
regardez on transpose des normes la
fabrication de la norme pose problème il
ya eu des progrès avec le traité de
lisbonne mais ça va pas assez loin du
tout mais moi je les ai vus dans
certains domaines d'ailleurs dans le
domaine des activés cemac sur les haies
sur le numérique sur les services
audiovisuels
non seulement la france parce
qu'autrement on dit que c'est l'europe
le problème et c'est nous qui sur
transposant dans les pays d'europe qui
sur transpose le plus donc le problème
c'est souvent nous et j'aime pas les
boucs émissaires non parce que ça cache
toujours nos propres faiblesses en
allemagne alors on va passer sous les
balles à la route de l'or il ya une
partie de ces institutions sont au bout
européenne donc il va bien voir à les
régénérer et les régénérer ça ne peut
être que dans le sens de projets communs
et de renforts démocratique mais sur la
l'assurance position mais on a su aussi
des textes qui non seulement une fois
qu'ils auront pour commencer est il que
les textes de transposition doivent à
nouveau être validé par les institutions
européennes enfin il faut arrêter le
délire vous voyez et la difficulté c'est
que quand vous n'avez pas de finalité
clairement affirmé quand vous n'avez pas
de projet d'intérêt général
l'organe
rés la fonction bureaucratique et etc je
passe mon temps à dire des exemples là
dessus mais donc du coup on s'intéresse
au détail l'europe doit pas s'intéresser
à tous les doit pas être une sorte elle
doit pas reprendre les travers de l'état
de l'état en france quoi qu'il a aussi à
inverser la charge de la preuve et qui
fait qu'il est chez matisse tout on
prévoit tout je pourrais vous en parler
on fait une pause on va en reparler de
la bureaucratie ont fait une heureuse on
se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
et l'on retrouve david lisnard le maire
de cannes
david lisnard
le coc vide ça a changé quoi pour un
politique tel que vous et pour la
politique en france 1 ça nous a ramenés
à notre condition humaine fragilité et
donc au rôle de la politique et du
politique comme toute crise violente
ce que l'on pensait être la règle c'est
à dire une sorte de paix et de sécurité
compris sanitaires
on a compris que dans les cycles longs
de l'histoire c'était l'exception et que
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est une
histoire de guerre hélas et l'épidémie
hélas et que la politique
on sait depuis offs 1 l'homme est un
loup pour l'homme et si vous ajoutez des
virus ça fait deux fléaux a besoin de le
gros le groupe a besoin de se protéger
et c'est pour ça qu'il a été inventé la
politique qui est le propre de l'espèce
humaine avec la prière et la production
artistique ça va encore pas faire
plaisir aux antispécistes mais on n'est
pas une espèce animale comme les autres
voilà on produit des oeuvres d'art ont
fait de la prière et ce qui n'enlève
rien à la sensibilité de l'être la cause
de l'animal évidemment pas des cartes
avaient tort et donc le coc vide nous a
ramenés à cette réalité que de la
fragilité du groupe la nécessité de
protéger le groupe 1 2
il a fallu trouver sur quelque chose que
l'on ne connaissait pas on connaissait
pas la létalité au début un jusqu'au
mois de mai juin 2020 on connaît pas
bien la létalité
c'est que ça tu peux que ça se propage
vite mais ça ce plantage vite ça tu peux
ça sature et enfin ça tu peux plus de
110000 mort enfin je sais pas combien
ont demandé mais c'est cette notion
relative notamment pour ceux qui en sont
victimes quoi mais en tout cas
ça nous ramène à ça à cette fragilité et
puis là il faut prendre des décisions et
il faut prendre des décisions sans avoir
de certitude et donc il faut pas être
manichéen bon moi j'ai été au fur et à
mesure je pense qu'il ya eu certaines
erreurs qui ont été faites aujourd'hui
on a une espèce d'euphorie en ce moment
on reviendra la réalité au printemps ou
à l'été prochain quand on sera plus dans
le quoi qu'il en coûte mais mais non
voilà ça a montré aussi des travers
français savent montrer le délire
bureaucratique va pas revenir là dessus
mais on a été apporté rien n'était pas
si mauvais enfin on comparera la réalité
des bilans et puis de ce qu'on a vécu où
on était en train de se sent à red hot
hot et de se faire des autos attestation
les on a jamais autant sorti nos chiens
et nos clébard dans la rue parce que
hors gros mois on allait faire un tour
enfin et c'était pas partout comme ça
c'était même une exception en france on
a fermé les librairies mais on le sait
les magasins de bricolage hoover et tant
mieux pour les magasins de bricolage
mais pourquoi une librairie où je peux
on a fermé les plages on a fermé les
plages des perles au début ça pouvait se
comprendre dans un premier temps c'est
le premier qu'on finance il fallait
qu'on ne savait pas comment se passerait
un confinement il fallait éviter les
regroupements de personnes donc mais on
a su très vite qui fait cette année une
bêtise au début il fallait le faire et
puis on a compris qu'on savait le
confiner mais de même qu'on nous je suis
une femme énervée et contre l'extrémisme
et on nous faisait pas faire de sport
dehors alors que moi j'étais dans ma
ville s'ils allaient faire du sport
dehors mais je peux pas appeler à la
désobéissance civile est bon et tout le
reste et tout le reste
l'interministériel pour autoriser les
sapins de noël et comme parce que il a
fallu au lieu de revenir sur la bêtise
bureaucratiques qui consiste à dire
qu'il ya des biens essentiels dans la
vie or c'est chaque individu qui sait ce
qui est essentiel pour lui moi le
bricolage est pas essentiel dans ma vie
et je suis admiratif du bricolage mais
il ya d'autres trucs qui sont essentiels
faire du sport bon on m'interdit de
faire du sport mais je pouvais me sauf
que je ne peux pas j'ai pas la plage et
l'impact moi je ne vais pas d'atelier
pour bricoler voilà donc qui sont ces
gens qui vous disent qu'il est essentiel
ou pas dans votre vie assez délirant
quoi et donc comme il y eut les sapins
de noël les marchands de sapins de noël
ont été plus efficaces que d'autres ils
ont réussi à montrer qu'il fallait voir
des sapins de noël il avait raison avant
noël il a fallu donc en france s'est
passé par une interministérielle avec un
des cribles je crois signée par quatre
ou cinq demi str ces dons ne faut pas
oublier tout ça donc et ensuite on voit
quand même le mécanisme il faut faire
très attention jeu on avait besoin de se
protéger
en moi je pense que de façon
circonstanciée limiter ce qu'on appelle
le pass annie terre a été une façon de
concilier l'efficacité face à la maladie
est de de retrouver une vie à peu près
normale nous on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
il faut pas s'habituer à la prolongation
de ce pass anita tout ça absolument
anormal de donner un pouvoir de
prolonger de telles obligations de
telles restrictions de même que on peut
plus passer par un conseil de défense et
mêmes cette terminologie alors qu'au
début c'est la guerre pour faire prendre
conscience de la gravité mais enfin je
crois qu'on est capable de prendre
conscience sans qu'on nous dise c'est la
guerre et dans d'autres pays il serait
arrivé si bien que tout ce en quoi et
puis la guerre c'est la continuation de
la politique par d'autres moyens c'est
requis un adversaire comme une
conscience un virus il a pas une
conscience il épate on me disait j'ai
entendu des ministres d'hier le virus et
sournois c'est toujours une image in
planqué quelque part en train de vous
dire tu comme s'il était donné une
conscience non c'est un virus avec des
critères scientifiques de contagiosité
de létalité et c'est donc tous ces
espèces de de personnalisation du mal là
c'est de l'infantilisation sac 7,7 ça
énerve les gens moi je pense que ça nous
aidez moi ça m'a énervé
sacré de la méfiance sacré de
l'incivisme et où donc où j'ai répondu à
plusieurs points mais il ya à la fois
des tendances lourdes historique de
l'humanité mais c'est plus qu'historique
qui sont propres à l'humanité les
épidémies la protection du groupe a
décidé de se protéger et puis d'un autre
côté il faut faire attention aux petits
glissements dont on peut tout comprendre
on comprend parfaitement les
restrictions de liberté lorsqu'elles
sont efficaces circonstancié limites et
faire attention à a l'habitude voilà à
l'habitude et je suis assez surpris
parfois de voir son nez dans le
complotisme dans des délires ans on voit
là moi je le fais je pense que bravo aux
chercheurs que vraiment et du vaccin je
crois pas qu'il ya un complot pour le
virus enfin voilà et d'un autre côté
d'eux
de s'habituer et ce qui m'a ce qui me
plaît pas alors là je refais un peu
politique plus circonstanciée là pour le
coup mais graduée aussi dans le temps
ces 7 mai qu'on trouvait déjà avant le
virus cette espèce de deux discours de
l'exécutif qui consiste à dire je suis
le seul et rationnelle et tous les
autres sont des extrémistes or on a le
droit arias des extrémistes il ya des
dingues il ya les complotistes fou bon
mais mais mais il ya en face un
conformisme très très arrogant quoi très
condescendant en un seul mot rassurez
vous et est il donc un moment donné on
peut manger très pro vaccination g on a
vacciné plus que partout ailleurs à
cannes et je les revendique et je
continue à le faire mais à un moment je
comprends qu'on se pose des questions
qu'on s'interroge on a besoin de
délibérations aujourd'hui on a le temps
maintenant de créer des vrais débats
s'il devait y avoir une prolongation du
passani terre ça peut pas se faire par
une loi qui donne un droit de tirage au
gouvernement de le mettre une palme est
c'est pas possible à monsieur voyez je
sais pas si ça répond à un voyage mais
ça a posé la question de l'état parce
que à la fois on a eu on s'est tournés
tous naturellement vers l'état à la fois
pour qu'il nous protège comme vous
l'avez dit mais aussi économiquement
d'ailleurs que l'état intervienne d'un
bâtiment il fermait tout il fallait
aussi qu'il fasse vivre les gens qui ne
pouvaient plus travailler et il l'a fait
mais en même temps l'autorité de l'état
nous a un peu fait peur parce qu'il a
pris de l'autorité à la fois parce qu on
était dans une une forme de dictature
sanitaire ce qu'on acceptait d'abord
parce que c'était c'était
ça n'était pas traitée d'urgence à nice
va là un état d'urgence les trains
d'état d'urgence qui mais qui peut
s'appeler comme on n'avait plus le droit
de sortir de chez soi on imaginait fait
pas un jour qu'on nous interdirait de
sortir de l'histoire on n'imaginait pas
qu'on aux règles le couvre feu pendant
six mois ni qu'il y aurait tous les
jours l'équivalent d'un crash aérien
entre 600 et 700 morts tous les jours
pendant des jours et des jours des
semaines et des mois c'était quelque
chose de très particulier mais en même
temps l'état était particulièrement
inquiétant arrogant alors la pratique
donc j'ai l'impression convaincu veille
dans les choquer les deux faces de
l'état à la fois on était content tu
reçois puissant et cette puissance nous
fait peur ça envoie là aussi il ya
beaucoup de choses circulent il est
normal qu'en ce alors on appelle ça
l'étape vers la puissance publique
puisque ça a été inventé pour ça pour
protéger le groupe et quel est l'état le
monopole de la violence légitime comme
comme la très nette dit max weber
ensuite le problème c'est que quand on
voit ce que vous étiez eu l'autorité
mais pas toujours il ya aussi de
l'autoritarisme et parfois un manque
d'autorité chaque mois j'ai vécu des
situations dans certains secteurs
géographiques ou le confinement ne
s'appliquait pas à tout le monde et où
l'état était faible avec les forts et
fort avec les faibles et ce qui est à
travers très français
réellement ou comme on n'a pas su faire
de deux micros isolement de personnes
contaminées on a fait des macros mesure
très pénalisante pour le groupe mais
parce qu'en france on isole pas les
malades voilà et whisky et c'est ce
qu'ils étaient enfin moi juge de là
dessus que j'ai donné il faut proposer
casser des oeufs pour faire une omelette
et jeudi il fallait mieux isoler de
façon un peu plus vie rigoureuse mais
les malades mais laisser plus de liberté
pour pour le groupe je me suis opposé
intellectuellement mais après la fameuse
phrase d'alain résistance et obéissants
sur les deux vertus de citoyens si on
résiste intellectuellement ans résiste
intellectuellement mais en habitant que
c'est légitime mais on a eu des moments
où on s'est posé la question moi je me
suis posé là quelque chose quand on pas
dans l'illégitime complet et ça se joue
à quelques semaines peut-être un
quelques jours et mais là dessus le y
avait des quartiers où il n'y avait pas
de confinement le soir où il y avait des
bandes entières dehors quoi et l'état ne
regardez pas vous voyez même désastreux
hausse était
lé premier couvre-feu après confinement
ça va être l'été 2020 ont dît je ne
regardais pas trop quoi et nous a envoyé
la police municipale mais ça te dérange
et je voyais bien que ça dérange et
l'état donc mais aussi en ville pour y
on s'était arrêté confie demande était
admirable des gens survivent dans des
toutes petites surfaces mais elle est
moche c'est pour ça que moi aujourd'hui
il faut ouvrir les espaces publics mais
si la règle s'applique elle doit
s'appliquer parce que parce que trop
vous créez de la justice c'est un
rapport de force est malheureusement
très souvent c'est ce qui arrive en
france donc il y avait parfois un peu d'
autoritarisme communicationnel montrer
qu'on allait contrôler la qui ont fait
dire la caravane médiatique puis à côté
de ça on voyait des situations qui était
anormal donc oui c'est inquiétant tout
ça avait mais comme vous l'avait dit
avant un crash d'avion par jour et est
donc c'était complet c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué pour les dirigeants le
ski ski en revanche n'est pas normal ça
a été les le fait d'apprendre cette
espèce de centralisation d'apprendre à
la télé les mesures y compris les
ministres et les préfets apprenez à la
télévision on aurait pu très bien
élaboré les trucs avant de façon dans la
confiance d'avoir des décrets
d'application qui sortait après les
dates d'application sur des trucs aussi
bête que l'ouverture des marchés
fermeture des marchés mais il ya des
vrais gens derrière qui vivent eux c'est
leur gagne pas et puis ces restrictions
infernale pour ça moi je dis pas que
l'état ne va pas apporter des aides aux
entreprises il a compensé il a indemnisé
cessé il ya vu un préjudice qu on peut
contester ou pas moi je pense que dans
un premier temps je peux comprendre le
premier confinement voit les autres
beaucoup plus de mal évidemment de
dérogation de l'ours était de moins en
moins de confinement et puis ces couvre
feu était assez absurde à la fin après
mois les restaurants étaient fermés de
faire un couvre feu le soir c'était
pourquoi pour quelles raisons pourquoi
j'aurais pas je ne pouvais pas aller
voir ma fille pourquoi enfin donc
non il ya eu il ya eu de l'arbitraire et
je pense mais vous même en tant que
maire donc avec des responsabilités des
responsabilités importantes vous en avez
pris d'ailleurs sur les masques sur les
vaccins vous avez eu des initiatives à
chaque fois en essayant de concilier
protection et libertés voilà toujours
été là jusqu'à la fin de mon propos
voilà est-ce que vous même vous êtes
retrouvés face à des situations
totalement inédite est ce que vous en
avez est ce que vous avez appris sur
votre métier parce que c'est un métier
mer vous apprenez toujours alors vous
avez raison d'abord c'est un métier où
on vous dit pas une profession enfin ça
nécessite de la professionnalisation et
mais comme à chaque crise quand j'ai eu
les inondations du 3 octobre 2015 un
phénomène d'une violence inouïe en
france en moins de deux heures de 2
litres d'eau fabre qui tombait dessus
c'était des u20 mordant dans le deuil
ses pensées comme york en a vu des
violences inouïes qu'un phénomène louis
et et vous devez prendre des décisions
tout de suite c'est aussi ce qui vous
rapproche de la population dire disent
qu'il faut être très fort dans
l'information il faut surtout pas faire
faire le concert ce que les
gouvernements savent surtout pas de
postures moralisant qu'il faut peut être
très sobre très informatif et puis
ensuite prend des décisions
bien sûr j'en apprends oui j'ai appris
pendant cette période d'abord vous
apprenez quand vous êtes confrontés à la
mort parce qu on est plus habitué à être
confrontés à la mort dans nos sociétés
et que ce soit pendant les inondations
ou pas cette période là vous êtes
confrontés à la mort vous voyez partir
des gens et vous accompagner des
familles et puis
oui plus beau jeu pas j'ai vu là là là
là j'ai eu la chance moi j'ai la chance
d'avoir une équipe formidable autour de
moi et ce qui m'a aidé à prendre des
décisions qui je pense était pas trop
certaines étaient plus ou moins bonnes
mais en tout cas je peux assumer
aujourd'hui parce que j'avais
aujourd'hui autour de moi des élus ou
des fonctionnaires ou des agents de
cabinet qui était remarquable qui
bossait jour et nuit et ça m'a permis de
voir à quel point ces équipes étaient
d'une dévouement magnifique et donc
l'homme n'est pas un loup pour l'homme
finalement bel et les deux c'est tout
les loups chassent en meute l'homme est
un loup pour l'homme la fameuse phrase
de up ce pour moi c'était vraiment une
phrase de droite et qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui fait que vous êtes de
droite vous savez pourquoi vous êtes de
droite ça va tout ça c'est des notions
est ce que ça veut dire quoi je pense
qu'on a besoin de clivage civilisé sir
contre on a pas de démocratie donc on
peut appeler ça conservateur pourrait
vivre ça à gauche d'or en france on dit
gauche droite pourquoi pas moi ma droite
à moi mais il y en a autant que de gens
de droite surtout les gens de droite on
est quand même assez pas loin des anars
parfois bientôt quelqu'un comme moi mais
c'est vous dire droite de là c'est cette
dialectique liberté responsabilité pour
moi c'est la matrice de tous est donc
d'abord d'essayer de faire sa vie soi
même avant d'aller chercher les autres
d'abord d'essayer de faire soigner sa
vie mais sa vie c'est l'a fait avec les
autres c'est aussi le bien commun c'est
le civisme mais c'est d'abord c'est ce
dont on a besoin en france aujourd'hui
c'est d'abord d'essayer de régler son
problème soi même et puis ensuite de le
faire avec le groupe moi je suis issu
d'une famille où mes parents sont autour
de ce monde autodidacte les gens sont
formidables mais jamais il serait venu à
l'idée d'aller voir un maire quand il
avait un problème vous voyez c'est donc
à des moments très durs et les moments
moins dure des moments faciles et moins
de prospérité on était dans le commerce
était armé donc pour moi c'est ça et c
et puis c'est le sens d'une
d'avoir esthétique dans le tragique quoi
d'une fausse et c'est peut-être ça de
droite c'est une espèce de poésie
d'esthétique de basse et prétendent mais
je pense qu'ils appliquent à moi mais
déléguant de ce cyrano de bergerac série
meurt c'est triste mais c'est pourquoi
il reste digne a le sens de l'honneur
c'est les troubles il ya plein de gens
de gauche qui ont le sens de l'honneur à
cette esthétique donc c'est les trois
mousquetaires ces dons et trois
mousquetaires de complètement mais mais
mais c'est magnifique et trois
mousquetaires puis ce sens de l'épopée
comme j'aimais bien discuté que dit il
n'ya qu'eux qui malheureusement nous a
quittés mais qui avait créé un très joli
qui s'appelait le retour d'artagnan
c'est ce qui me fait penser et sens de
l'esthétique dans l'épopée
en a bien le collectif mais c'est quand
c'est pour marquer des buts au foot ou
pour au rugby pour le pack kouame mais
quand on peut choisir six mois si vous
me demandez de d'arriver à l'heure je
vise d'être en retard 6 6 me demandez
rien chez en avant soyez cc c'est ça
aussi un petit peu l'esprit de droite
peut-être piste et alors quelle
différence y at-il avec qui on appelle
l'extrême droite et qui s'occupe
d'extrême droite qui elle même se dit
qu'elle est la droite qu'elle ait pas
plus que jamais je pense ce soit marion
maréchal que j'ai reçue alors maillot
marine le pen où il est mort il vous
dira jamais on est l'extrême droite il
vous dit on et la droite jeu je pense
d'abord on est toujours extremis de
quelqu'un parce que m'arrive maintenant
qualifié de droite dure j'ai eu
récemment parfois je me sens à gauche et
les gens droite de la droite et les gens
de gauche mais ça l'esprit de
contradiction c'est pour la dialectique
non mais je crois que la différence
c'est
c'est peut-être que
dans l'histoire en tout cas c'est pas
théorisé chez ces personnes là qui ont
des qualités et défauts comme tout le
monde mais c'est le bouc émissaire c'est
que moi je pense que l'extrémisme à
tendance mais extremis de gauche aussi
aaaaah extérieure à nous extérioriser de
notre responsabilité est à voir dans ce
qui nous arrive toujours une en tout cas
de négatif une responsabilité que ça
alors ça peut arriver il ya des méchants
il ya des adversaires il ya des des
complots c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
complotistes qui a pas de complot et
donc tout ça tout ça tout ça est vrai
mais
cessé de chercher forcément une de nous
exonérer de nos propres responsabilités
et je peut il me semble que c'est un
point commun de l'extrémisme et donc de
tomber dans une flatterie dans une
démagogie qui consiste à au bout d'un
moment d'en faire un système et
donc de désigner de façon extrêmement
simple monolithique le mal quoi le sait
ce que vous reprochez aussi au mouvement
boc avait complètement d'avoir érigé
l'homme blanc en bouc émissaire mais
c'est une catastrophe s'étant faut bien
reconnaître que dans l'histoire l'homme
blanc était restent pour saab d'un
certain nombre de problèmes il en a
parfois aussi trouver la solution mais
mais mais je suis absolument pas ce
raisonnement non l'homme est responsable
en général donc l'homme blanc l'homme
noir
le l'homme jaune quoi enfin mais mais
mais regardez l'histoire de l'humanité
et les sociétés qui à un moment donné on
fait des révolutions technologiques ont
naturellement chercher à s'étendre et
parfois avec des abominations comme il
ya eu des meurtres des crimes de guerre
la colonisation qui a produit des crimes
etc mais c'est pas intrinsèque à l'homme
blanc penser que c'est un tracé que le
blanc c'est une forme de racisme et ça
que le racialisme qui est qui et qui
tombait dans le wok dans l'autisme comme
la cancel cultures et toutes ces
inepties dangereuse avec des systèmes
très très holistique très simple très
opérationnelle totalitaires comme comme
tous les totalitarismes comme
l'islamisme et
cdd désigne des boucs émissaires et et
ne voient déjà rien que le mot racisées
je trouve qu'il est raciste c'est à dire
qu au nom de l'antiracisme on revend
réinstaure la notion de race moi
j'appartiens à une génération où on la
race était c'était ça n'existait plus
quoi enfin je
jugerai ça existe encore pour ceux qui
ont la pression et au revoir et non mais
de s'ouvrir avant l'heure rien que ce
terme de mai il ya du racisme et ses
apps c'est abominable crcc condamner
quelqu'un non pas pour ce qu'il fait
pour ce qu'il est pour qu' il faut
évidemment condamné le racisme il ya de
la discrimination au même même si j'aime
paris terme c'est une réalité il faut la
condamner
c'est l'honneur des civils non
utilisation que d'avoir défini ce que
c'était que le racisme et de la voir et
qu'elle a dit est la discrimination en
avoir fait même des circonstances
aggravantes dans le code pénal il ya
beaucoup de civilisations on se pose pas
la question bon et
ces voix qui sont tellement dans leur
système qui est qu'ils ont avec le terme
racisées le vous pouvez vous n'êtes pas
racisées vous c'est à dire moi je ne
suis pas raciste mais pourquoi moi je te
racisées comme tout le monde si les
autres s'en racisées oh non je pense que
je me dis ça mais en fait je ne veux pas
être assise et du tout et je ne vois pas
l'autre comme mais dont courriers
lettres mais il s'agit d'un symbole
sexuel mais ça me considère comme racine
mais mais mais mais tout cela n'a aucun
sens dans le sens où on y l'universalité
de l'homme et c'est pour ça que le
système est français l'universalisme
républicain et l'indisposent autant tous
ces gens là c'est parce que
leur fond de commerce leur système quand
c'est justement le mot important c'est
systémique c'est à dire que vous
imaginez ce totalitarisme vous n'êtes
plus en mesure moi ce que je dis là
n'est même pas audible parce que de
toute façon je suis un homme blanc et en
plus je puis 50 piges donc donc j'ai
donc c'est c'est une forme de
totalitarisme qui consiste à ne plus
entendre l'argument de l'autre mais alex
communier et j'utilise le terme à
dessein parce que parce qu'il n'est
c'est une forme de racisme auj le
racialisme et un racisme le crocis mhz
et est une violence et d'une violence
inouïe parce que exclus du débat et de
la capacité de produire de l'idée des
individus façon partir donc il faudrait
soit s'auto flageller soit être un
mais je ne suis pas un et
je m'auto flagey leur est pas d'être ce
que je suis ce qui n'empêche pas de
regarder l'histoire avec lucidité et les
meurtres commis par chacun avec lucidité
et racialiste en arrive à dire où les
wackies sous forme pour le temps que
vous voulez que l'esclavagé est une
invention des blancs ce qui est
totalement faux j'ai eu de l'esclavagé
quasiment sous toutes les civilisations
et dans toutes les couleurs de peau 1 et
quand les délices et du colonialisme
aussi donc c'est une hérésie historique
et ça devient un fascisme ça devient
totalitarisme et c'est en ça qu'on se
retrouve beaucoup avec des gens de
gauche qui pense comme nous enfin vous
donc qu'ils sont qui ont qui sont pétris
de liberté d'égalité de fraternité c'est
à l'universalisme républicain on ne peut
pas accepter d'être enfermé de façon
identitaire passé jour par le racialisme
c'est pas possible la grande différence
c'est qu'ils perdent longtemps
l'antiracisme
c'était quand on était anti raciste on
voulait que tout le monde soit les mêmes
aujourd'hui
cette forme d'anti racisme là que vous
appelez le mouvement wac
c'est que le racisme et pour que tout le
monde soit différent donc le but n'est
pas le même
c'est un régime de la diversité sauf
d'opinion 1 vous remarquez certes la
diversité c'est bien sauf la diversité
des opinions parce que c'est vrai tu
n'acceptes absolument pas une contre
opinion et c'est comme ça qu'ils en
arrivent par la violence pas que
symbolique d'ailleurs déviation du terme
devient symbolique mais pas que sur les
symboles pas que morale on va dire pas
avoir empêché des conférenciers devient
de l'université a molesté des gens
philip roth d'or dans la tâche dans son
roman manipulateur j'avais tout vu donc
non mais mais mais même quand je vois un
copain un ami interlocuteur je regarde
pas si les blancs jaunes ou noirs c'est
pas mon problème c'est ses accessoires
voyez ce que je veux dire en revanche si
la victime de racisme parce qu'il est
noir c'est scandaleux et on doit
condamner l'acte raciste qui est une
négation de justement que pour moi du
progrès de l'humanité j'ai testé ma
question est ce que vous y croyez encore
au progrès je crois en progrès mais je
suis progressiste grande différence oui
je crois que je pense que quand vous
regardez la révolution numérique
le bouleversement des anneaux
technologies le
clara de messages et c'est peut-être une
des plus grandes inventions de 2 sur une
période de 30 40 ans et que ça va
apporter évidemment des progrès puissant
contre la maladie des progrès pour la
prospérité et que n'en déplaise aux eaux
tous les apocalyptique qui font que nos
gamins sont malheureux des djeun enfin
c'est délirant quoi je pense que dans 30
40 ans il y aura des conditions de vie
qui seront bien meilleurs qu'aujourd'hui
et que la famille n'aura reculé à
condition qu'on ne soit pas régressif
qu'on ne soit pas des croix sioniste
cuba comme on dit des croissants et de
défendre east et donc et écureuils et
qu'on n'oublie jamais que le progrès est
porteur de d'un gain potentiel pour
l'humanité mais aussi de danger
croissant c'est
symétrique c'est à dire que la
révolution industrielle a apporté
beaucoup quoi qu'on en dise il ya moins
de familles d'aujourd'hui beaucoup moins
de famine qu'avant il ya beaucoup moins
de gens qui meurent de faim grâce au
capitalisme à la révolution industrielle
etc mais parallèlement le machinisme et
la révolution industrielle a aussi
apporté la mort de masse a apporté la
grosse bertha 14-18 et puis les camps de
concentration en 39-45 et qu'aujourd'hui
la révolution numérique le
transhumanisme le la robotique son
porteur d'immenses progrès potentiel
mais qui sont aussi porteurs de 2,2
c'est là que l'homme de droite vigilant
ou paix civile suit pas ce que vous
direz mais s'exprime sont aussi porteurs
d'agréer nation symétrique et qu on en
revient toujours à la nécessité de
réinventer de régénérer plutôt inventer
le l'humanisme science sans conscience
n'est que ruine de l'âme donc on doit
progresser sur le plan philosophique
autant qu on progresse sur le plan
scientifique autrement il y aura de
regarder le système chinois et vous
verrez ce que les technologies de
reconnaissance faciale ça peut apporter
la protection ça peut apporter de
l'aliénation il nous reste une minute
votre dernier livre c'est la culture
nous sauvera que vous avez écrit avec
christophe tardieu qui est paru aux
édition de l'observatoire vous pensez
vraiment que la culture nous sauvera
parce qu'elle nous divise aussi c'est
une exhortation
c'est une espérance
l'espérance c'est un risque à courir
comme de droite bernanos bernanos et
oui moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans une
société fragmentée éclatée
genre pour qu'elle a très bien c'est
devenu presque un concept commun lâché
prise à sion le fait de dire que qu'on
soit riche ou pauvre que l'on soit
d'origine bretonne ou provençal ou
maghrébine au cap verdienne on a on est
dépositaire d'un patrimoine commun que
l'on peut transmettre que l'on doit
transmettre et qui nous permet à la fois
nous ai pensé nous émanciper on peut se
faire un capital culturel qui nous
émanciper individuellement d'être libre
et on a aussi une horizontalité sierra
bien commun une cohésion sociale
condition civilisationnel donc je pense
qu'on est face à un virage
civilisationnel danger civilisationnel
un enjeux civilisationnels et que la
culture entendu comme la transmission
des grandes oeuvres de l'esprit et la
production de gros oeuvre parce que les
grands le patrimoine c'est une création
si l'ancien création et que tout n'est
pas culture contrairement à ce qu'on
nous a raconté pendant des années et
comme un art est la terre c'est notre
héritage ne posséder aucun testament
disait rené char dans les feuillets
d'hypnos skis ski et hannah arendt ans
dans la crise de la culture définit
cette singularité de l'oeuvre qui
résiste à son auteur et qui c'est qui
est une quête une la création culturelle
c'est une rupture entre le passé et
l'avenir cette présent mais c'est ce
présent qui va devenir lui-même un
élément de transmission du patrimoine
cgc cette pensée belle et elle est
complexe et jusqu'à la mort on peut la
halle à complexifier tout est donc oui
la culture peut nous redonner de l'unité
de l'espérance à la fois de la quête des
chances individuel c'est bon pour lutter
pour l'égalité des chances et aussi de
l'unité civilisationnel en a tellement
besoin un pote on est tellement
fragmenté tellement éclaté donc la
culture seul ne sauvera pas il faut la
prospérité mais c'est aussi une source
de prospérité pour la prospérité
économique mais l'unité civilisationnel
plus l'ordre régalien juste l'ordre
juste aurait dit ségolène royal à juste
titre eh bien c'est ce qui peut nous
sauver merci à vous d'être venu dans
interdit d'interdire merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]